- WHOA, BOYS.
MEGA-SALE AT
BURLINGTON COAT FACTORY?
- [laughs]
NO.
WE HIT THE BAR.
- THE DENIM BAR.
- WE LIVIN' THAT SNIPE LIFE NOW.
- BASICALLY WE DRESS LIKE
WESLEY SNIPES NOW
'CAUSE WE CAN AFFORD TO
WITH OUR SIDE JOBS.
- THAT'S GOOD FOR YOU,
BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO WORK
AT THIS JOB.
- OH, DON'T MAKE ME GO
FULL-BLOWN CLOWN ON YOUR ASS.
- OKAY, I DON'T EVEN WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
- WHAT HE'S TRYIN' TO TELL YOU
IS THAT YOU ARE LOOKING
AT RANCHO CUCAMONGA'S
PREMIER CLOWN TROUPE.
WHAT YOU ARE EXPERIENCING
RIGHT NOW
IS CALLED TROUPE ENVY.
- WELL, YOU'RE ABOUT
TO EXPERIENCE
MY HEEL IN YOUR MANHOLE
IF YOU DON'T GET ON
THE PHONES NOW,
AND PLEASE, TRY TO DRESS
LIKE LOSERS WHO WORK HERE.
THANKS.
- I THOUGHT WE LOOKED COOL.
- YEAH.
- WE LOOK VERY SOLID.
- WE LOOK--YEAH.
WE LOOK COOL.
- HEY, IF YOU GUYS
ARE AVAILABLE,
MY NIECE IS HAVING
A BIRTHDAY.
- $150 A POP.
- MM-HMM.
- BUT WE'LL GIVE YOU
THE FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
$100 AND NO PHOTOS.
- OKAY.
- ALSO THIS LIST OF THINGS
THAT WE WANT.
- YUP.
- THE PICKLES CAN BE MIDGET.
BUT THE CHEETOS BETTER BE
PUFFY.